hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to an early preview of the
Dead Space 3 demo now I got access to
this I'm very happy to try it out for
you guys I'm playing it on the Xbox
because the demo is not available on the
PC so I had to get this in here to go on
so basically the gist of the demo is
just to give a feature of the features
that are available in the stuff like you
know better with Kinect it's got those
voice command things that they want you
to use it's also got weapon crafting now
weapon crafting is something and I don't
really know about because as far as I
know it probably involves those
workbenches from dead space 1 & 2 but
that just had to do with the power node
so let's go take a look at what the
weapon crafting is all about I'm
actually excited about it I mean I mean
there's a co-op campaign that I might
try later oh hello
use this from to test out one of the
thousands of deadly tools and weapons
that Isaac can craft enter the bench to
begin crafting then use a nearby switch
to test your weapon on enemies you have
unlimited health ammo and stasis in this
room cool oh so we got our standard said
we have unlimited ammo who things are
looking good you know it's hard to tell
but I just recently played the Dead
Space 1 on impossible because I love the
dead space campaign all the games and
I'm sure that 3 is going to be great but
um it's definitely got the dead space
feel but it is looking phenomenal it's
hard to believe that this is still on
the Xbox oh there's the bench because I
mean the Xbox 360 is getting old it's
over when 8 years old now and it's
looking phenomenal as good as any game
on the PC that I can see all right let's
see you blueprints weapon upgrades craft
items a safe obviously so there's
apparently oh cool I like this you know
customization in the game is one thing
but if it's implemented correctly it can
be pretty cool alright upper tool uh
weapon defaults rotate okay alright so
let's look at the upper tool woops sorry
I went out of it up
left weapons slot off to look at that
later okay so we got plasma core and
military engine increases the speed of
the the firing rate increases the damage
increases the speed again at the cost of
reload and clip size that creases reload
and speed losing clip size it seems to
be the best upgrade that I can see so
let's pick that one pneumatic torch
ha ha ha see uh come on yeah yeah oh
yeah there we go all right sorry not
used to the Xbox controller just yet
craft new tip no parts available ok so
lower tool let's look at was the lower
tools that the secondary fire let's get
the let's get the old plasma core in
there and then the frame which I'm
guessing is just the look of it let's
get something different and attachment
to flame goz minor fire damage
automatically reloads after emptying
increases clip size of self and partner
hey that's not bad
stasis coats projectile with very small
about to say stasis hell yeah I want
that
holy hell yeah then circuit upgrades ah
these are the power node upgrades that
were there before so let's get the
gavage up way up on the damage ooh
damage and reload what not what they
weren't kidding when they fed there are
thousands of different complications
complications combinations man look at
all of this you can spend the whole game
looking at the crafting setup this is
awesome okay so let's just get um oh
wait are those oh no those are
detrimental stuff ok nevermind I thought
those were double bonuses alright so
let's just get the damage and rate of
fire in there
let's get ready to fire damage made of
fire let's just keep going for that
sounds good to me
reload rate of fire who needs it
more damage damage and a double Davidge
okay so we got our double damage weapon
so this thing is doing pretty awesome
could get skinned ammo where's it stasis
mamo sweeper automatically picks up ammo
these things are awesome
oh I can't wait for the game that's it's
crazy oh man so happy that I got a
chance to play this before everyone else
hahahaha alright cool the demo will be
released for everyone I believe on the
22nd but craft a new weapon what I am
I'm wasting way too much time military
engine hahaha you're gonna grab it up is
that what I just made I made a totally
new engine holy crap our new weapon I'm
having way too much fun just crafting
stuff probably not exciting for you so
let's get into the business I've been
wasting far too much time on the
crafting let's get to the killing
alright where can I get enemies weapons
switch alright this is the one that I
made oh yes was the secondary fire okay
those stasis that's Kinesis I haven't
played it on the Xbox so I have no idea
what's my secondary fire here oh just
normal plasma beams cool how do i sprint
let's see all right enough reloading
there Isaac how do I run ah good old
stop it II mother fer alright they said
something about unlimited enemies here I
want to know
can't get can't pull down out
can't hold on oh ah I don't get to test
my awesome device it's left bumper to
Sprint though by the way oh dang it
all right well by the looks of it I'm
not gonna get any enemies if I don't
know how I don't know where to get them
so uh let's get into the actual demo
here that was enough of a look at
crafting I mean that's just one of the
aspects of it I obviously can't hello
nice little trailer there for you guys
who haven't seen that does I don't think
I've seen that trail before and I've
been following a lot of the dead space
stuff so there you go all right so we
are gonna try the solo campaign the
other features that I can't test are on
the Kinect because I don't own a Kinect
but basically connect means you can
shout shoes day so senator use stasis on
you but I mean personally and this is
just me thanks for downloading the Dead
Space 3 demo ain't no problem babe three
features for you today you can
experience all the classic dead space
thrills in single-player mode yes main
character Isaac Clarke yeah Oh for the
first time you can team up with a friend
and experience our seamless drop in drop
out I don't have an interest story and
dialogue change from single-player
mmm-hmm also don't skip the weapon
crafting room I just did back and use it
to modify the weapons you find in the
game huh or create weapons of your own
from the sky that's what I wanted to
figure out how did I get the enemies to
spawn the bench with just some of the
items that you could scavenge in your
game we hope you enjoy the demo and
thanks for checking it out thank you
thank you baby I'm her more than happy
to check it out after breaking up on
reentry Isaac wakes up to discover
himself stranded on the hostile plains
of Al volantis with his crew scattered
or possibly dead Isaac's only option is
to press forward in hopes of finding a
way to survive sounds familiar
so I didn't know that the story changed
from solo bladed co-op play that means
that would open up options because I
would like that because that means I
could play through the campaign alone
and then team up with someone and played
in co-op hello hello you beautiful
creature
wake up Isaac rise and smell the ashes
he's not looking so good
dan is Haise his face is about half
frozen off
yeah
yes there we go I always do appreciate a
game that lets people play the demo and
to play a demo before the game is
released it's just well it's good
marketing strategy but it also gives us
a chance to get a good look at it and
hopefully it won't reveal any anything
too much about the story leave the story
due finishing the game itself
I do like the idea that there you know I
used to be kind of apprehensive about
the idea of it just being I know I know
I know I know I know I'll go back and
forth between the members strategically
dismembered blah blah blah I was
apprehensive at first about it not being
in space I mean I'm sure there are gonna
be places in space it's called dead
space but then I thought about it more
because the original because the
original let's see how do I get my
objective marker was it what did I do
what did what button did I press I
pressed a couple okay I hold down left
bumper that's it okay that's it right
bumper sorry but then I thought more
about because the original dead space it
was all the same because it was all in
the same ship and the environment was a
little I don't know oh I have help okay
good he's a B apparently he's quick heal
so that's cool oh I like the way the
snow forms around my feet sorry it's
just little things I like to notice the
little details and things like this yeah
gotta get through this no my name's
Isaac Clark gotta find Ellie
gotta find dying in the snow I can
barely say even though space is zero
degrees
this can't be a little more than
negative few although it's still really
cold yeah that is some whyzard why I
would have plan to be colder than space
bad alright game logic press right
button to stop on corpses and good
painters truck out John duh
heard something duh my name's Isaac
Clark got a stop on things everything I
say
actually I think I sound more like my
coffee partner [ __ ]
Oh where'd you come from whoa what the
hell is that
Holly balls what are you Jesus
oh I cut his friggin pores Oh off in its
bluth what ha ha ha
holy crap ok I got came out of nowhere
sorry if I already reloaded the mic I'm
right up next to it man that was awesome
ah all right moving forward from that
duh how's it Clark snow enemy's gonna
stop me alright I'm finally out of the
blizzard I don't think you guys
appreciate my as a clerk voice do I have
Knuth yeah I do
surprisingly okay ah Wow holy crap
whoa he just yeah okay that's freaky
that's normal I'm perfectly Norman okay
I shoot the arms off and then okay right
bumper to change the oscillation of oh
give me those semiconductor what's that
what are these things are these the
scavenger balls ammo clip ammo cartridge
compatible with all weapons and tools ah
I guess if there's going to be unlimited
customization that was a necessary
trade-off because um I I'm not all for
homogeneous a ssin but I can see the
logic behind that one if you're gonna
have a stupid huge amount of tools make
the other pickups weapon part bound
Tesla core yeah if they're gonna be
pickups like weapon customization you're
gonna need to keep some huh hegemony
working right so ammo clip is now all
uniform and you could take that take
that for what it is I can see the
potential in it and you can see like
there tons of resources off to the side
that could invariably mean on a
smorgasbord of possible implications
implementations of things I'm not
looking good I'm bleeding all over the
place I think my suit has ruptured maybe
that's why I'm so leaden cold oh look at
this snow around my feet I'm not weird
to be excited about that the fact that
snow piles up around my feet like that
so weird
haha you'll familiar Isaac Clark scream
uh uh what's going on yeah okay so I
still can't run any faster than this but
oh yes I can
oh sorry I'm an idiot oh I thought I
thought for sure oh hello
that's bad ah Oh bud left left what look
sick of Jun I'm a computer gamer you
can't do this to me
hey hey I know it's button is a it's
suck if I fail this way or left left
stick left I'm left sticking as hard as
I can stick I'm not sticking I'm
sticking get it spin it die a one damn
Isaac Clark is a badass
I've always known this I mean owes he's
dealt with all the insanity that deals
with the marker I've actually read the
book the dead space book I'm a huge huge
fan of dead space Wow look at that that
is awesome
I'm assuming that this is based on a
planet where they found another the red
markers the red markers are copies of
the black marker the black marker was
originally found in earth I'm underneath
the crater in the Gulf of Mexico and I
read the book about them this the
founding of all men in the whole unit
ology theory
oh yeah run cattle run I'm taking in the
scenery game still can't believe that
Xbox can do this on ancient technology
man I can't wait I've heard rumors that
the new Xbox is gonna come out either
next year the year after so it shouldn't
be too long
military engine I remember seeing that
on the weapon crafting whoa whoa hey
how's it i was complacent for a second
oh yo yo hold your hold up buddy do me I
got to get used to my old my old dead
space senses because I was doing pretty
good on impossible I may actually beat
it on my own if I just feel like doing
it every once in a while cuz I'm a bit
of a I'm a bit of a technophile I love
technology and I loved nerding out over
things like game engines and
improvements to graphics and stuff like
that like it's one of my big weaknesses
I absolutely love seeing new technology
unfold and especially when is unfolding
in my favorite games like dead space and
yes guys I might come on hey
[Music]
yeah [ __ ] okay uh uh I'm Isaac Clark
okay okay Carter I'll meet you inside
we'll be okay too bad we're not working
together cuz I have no friends
what's in here is this a Dingle Engel
Kinesis grab one of my book press ah I
just jammed the be bun okay go whoa
soot kiosk hell yeah the Arctic survival
suit oh hell yeah let's get it get to a
chase shoot
ah but sing with me always dramatic
music is playing okay I always be
worried about that mangle in me like oh
you bet the left arm oh I thought you
met your penis like and it rips
everything off looking good good you got
that blood cleaned off yeah I don't know
how that suits any better than a suit
that's designed to survive in space or
whatever see you if I can upgrade my rig
upgrade my health huh don't have any
whoo they took away the power nodes No
alright let's just upgrade my health I
got a ton of stuff so I might as well
just keep upgrading up nope I'm out
so manic jellies alright get armor come
in my armor the armor oh I just can't I
can't quick gave gone god don't stop you
know how I get called go get a real I
cool
stasis nope out but I can do the
recharge durability
alright sweet looking good
alright that seems to be it nope I can
do a little bit more a little bit of the
range and that'll be it yep that is it
alright I am fully upgraded with all
their they have given me I'm not gonna
try to be weapon graphic now that takes
too long I just I just be tough I'd be
messing around with it for far too long
right
so apparently the co-op campaign changes
in that the soul campaign has the
character in there but he's just never
with them so I could see how that would
change hi hey buddy
oh hey
I don't appreciate that hi it's good I
know duh I'm Isaac Clark that didn't
hurt at all
God took a badass just need a rub my
neck for a bit oh hello I get to bite
you alright shoot the yellow what oh
damn oh hi [ __ ]
hide your [ __ ] you who you think you're
better with but I'm dr. Clark
I love king of the kill you the how do i
stasis you there we go did you come out
to David Clark I kill the marker I
killed it dude oh [ __ ] I'm now good with
consoles I guess that's tough
I said Clark missed again Isaac or we'll
miss the third time hey if that fall off
or is that still there whoa whoa whoa
hey hey pop your little things here
those guys are these mutations have big
glowing yellow spots for their
weaknesses well oh where you going are
you leaving
go you can't handle logic Clark you guys
are pretty annoyed in my eyes and Clark
boys aren't you okay that's not what he
sounds like no duh why should Clark
doesn't care how's your Clark child's
what Isaac Clark wants to sound like
alright enough enough silence I'm
supposed to be doing a serious preview
for the game is the condition of me
kidding Dutch ha ha ha ha
ok what is this I don't know contains
resources in rare parts a spare part box
ok cool a nice little doodad so far I'm
absolutely loved hello I'm absolutely
loving to you oh I see what's going on
here they found a specimen frozen in the
sand that worked out very well for the
movie the thing you know how all the
people in the movie survived and went
home to see their family Oh Oh No oh
yeah oh well I guess Isaac Clark will
survive to live another day now what I
don't know is and what I don't think it
is I don't think that ok you're really
dead
ok you're really dead well I don't think
that the Mokka has a plan
you will be reborn Isaac Clark must die
the future of our religion of our very
waste depend upon it
stop him at any cost okay number one
that voice sounds very familiar from
Dead Space 1 the scientist guy that was
trying to help you and to Arthur Clarke
don't take no [ __ ] from you okay never
that I guess I didn't need to pull those
boxes up here if I was just gonna be
able to get them right away whatever are
you ready for what
no oh holy crap I get to fight real
human enemies
ha ha ha your leg off bruh
oh grenade oh who did that oh I'll just
let them fight out their own battle for
the moment listen whoa hey hey yeah
that's right oh you found out who I was
you don't mess with the judge Clark
by the way no I'm not gonna yeah I'm
totally like the worst with um the Xbox
so don't judge me for my piss-poor aim
because it's bad but I can see getting
used to it I mean when it comes to
accuracy between the Xbox and console
can Xbox in the keyboard/mouse
there's really just no comparison in the
precision that you can get but I could
get used to it if it's required for the
game it's all about the game breath
oh hello hey boys oh hey yo you slow
down and I gotta hang on let me good
strategic like Gotama say yes see you
good bye okay getting better get my
impossible skills back up in it back up
in it gonna get it to win it
yeah alright so gonna get so fun once in
here hang on what's over there let me
just check everything there might be
some secrets in the demo like some
Easter eggs you never know okay nothing
over there compressor I'm finding a lot
of parts man I'm [ __ ] in tada parts it
would be crazy to think how many parts
you can find in the rest of the game
what was that I was talking sorry I'm
sorry
Hey Wow
water Wow oh no you did no way dad oh it
was one of those head crawly thingies ha
shut up no need under to know you don't
you die oh man
that was like the freakiest day ever
okay so for this one do you actually aim
no hey you stop
almost almost stomp them this out of you
Jesus oh man that was the most
disturbing thing I've seen right as far
as an enemy goes I just don't like that
idea of something ripping your head off
even if you're dead something ripping
your head off and then taking its place
in your neck that was the way that you
could guy that was a secret way that you
could die in Dead Space 1 not really
secret but if that thing starts
strangling you around your neck it would
literally squeeze your head off cut your
head off
and dig down your neck and it was them
it was the most disturbing thing I've
ever seen in my life oh hello
that's a bigan Glenn looks like one of
the monsters that I killed in Dead Space
1 me oh there's more of them holy crap
there's a bunch of them oh don't tell me
that whole mountain is a gigantic 100 I
don't know maybe maybe maybe not that
may or may not be the truth
okay man these guys do not know how to
survive apocalypses help you out huh
yeah buddy so long as you don't oh I did
not help you out I'm so sorry man I'm so
sorry I uh whoa I did not help you out
man
hahahaha look at the sex is so cool
damn I mean this is just the freakiest
[ __ ] ever
I I can't believe I ever had doubts and
the more than I'm seeing it the more its
remnants reminding me of like the thing
you know the thing movies wha hi hi hi
you little shits need us shut up and
slow down where did those come from oh
man this is so freaky there's like so
many ways for these enemies to die and
change into different rats it's kind of
freaky but awesome at the same time like
you know whenever there's a sequel
you're always gonna be expected to
improve on things and them as far as I
can tell everything that I'm seeing is
just constant improvement okay am I
going through there and let me see
what's up here like everything about it
just stellar I love it all of it okay
that's locked I don't have one I need to
get through there apparently or
something I gotta get through here lemme
in it's cold it's cold
all right so carrying on here what do we
got really pretty interior I like that
the loading loading times are down I
haven't even noticed a single loading
screen they used to do a trick where
you'd wait at the door but I mean right
now oh haha okay so I gotta clear that
what is that noise um a giant drill
blocking my way out maybe I can lower
the safety gates did that why one way to
find out how did I find Ellie I'm
thinking the demo may have skipped a few
things and I've totally forgotten what I
was talking about yeah it wasn't that
important it was just me blathering on
about whatever in the hell I blather on
about wait what
apparently there's a lot more things
that you can do Kinesis oh boy hello
early i'm trimmed the drills trying to
kill me quit no yeah there's a there's a
yellow fuse in the center Wow whoa whoa
whoa why is this drill trying to kill me
Oh where'd you come from hi hi do I need
to stasis the drill that makes sense I
don't know what stasis is other than
magic but it's frickin awesome god damn
these things do not die they're not as
simple as just hang on there son okay I
see a holdup god deal with some hair why
I'm dead [ __ ] yeah hang on
- stasis recharge okay now you've done
getting all up in my grill let me
exercise my right to destroy these
things I'm Isaac Clark I destroy all
technology I see always no exception
let's go beyond
oh hi where'd you come from
I can't exactly clear the deck okay I'm
assuming a stone a to shoot the thing
okay you just you hold on I need to do
[ __ ] odd amount of stasis Oh God alas -
ah I run down that's like chaotic
everything I can't even tell us going on
and it's kind of Awesome okay gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme you miss dick
okay oh wow what's that fro Dodge that's
what I thought
hi step off buddy I need to get this in
here Oh
50% oh crap one
oh so boned this one hell of a boss
fight
hang on hang on hold on hold on there we
go
what the hell was that whoa hang on
what was that there was something there
that I've never seen before I knew it
springing okay all right whoa hey wow
that was a crazy imagine of bossfight
right there and I love it I love it look
at all these goodies god I love it I
didn't take a single hit point of damage
there I'm thinking because the game is
like okay this guy's this guy's an idiot
good let's let's not let's not throw I'm
too big of a challenge here cuz those
guys those enemies were hitting me but
there was one enemy that was like this
really thin type enemy I'd never seen it
was kind of freaky er than the other
ones let me out here this is giant drill
trying to kill me I need to get back to
Ellie hey it's me
Isaac look well hello ru ah whoa okay
they're the enemies on you guys our
allies their enemy
hey you can't mess with me
Eliza Clark baby Masumi a headshot works
better than dismember for you guys right
what was that
yeah come on oh hi what did you get here
whose Norton
oh hey hey hey we'll put holy crap that
thing's big
oh I get you Oh nope oh damn it
no ah mother I wanted to JA goddamn okay
man I was crazy awesome oh you guys have
already seen this I'll just see if I can
skip through it by the looks of it now
you're gonna wash it again sorry but
either way that was friggin awesome
oh man I if I had any one doubts about
this game they've been as swage the
gameplay was awesome I mean there
weren't any horror moments in what I
seen but I'm willing to bet that there's
plenty of well I mean I was startled
quite a few times at a few jump scares
there but I mean I'm willing to bet that
there's tons of different things it's
gonna be a lot of different varied
environments
I am definitely definitely excited about
this game and I'm definitely definitely
gonna do a full let's play of it so as
soon as it's released expect a full
let's play because I am very very eager
i love the dead space franchise to death
ever since i first played it i can't
believe i put it off as long as I have I
mean I ate everything up about it I read
the book the book was alright but like
just the whole story about it I love it
love it love it so thank you all so much
for watching when the demo comes out I
will let you guys know that so that you
guys could try it out for yourselves ah
just as a reminder I was just playing on
an earlier release so you can't get it
just yet but when you do let me know
what you think of it so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done click the
link in the description I think to get
your name in um maybe get an early
access demo I'm not sure I remember I
just remembered something about that so
be sure to check the description either
way for any link so thank you again and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
find this boy whoa whoa hey hey I hear
zone it nothing get out
come on
[Music]